behind me is the scent lawrence seaway
one of the largest public works projects
in North America's history the Seaway
was a 1950s expansion of small canals
and waterways into a huge navigable path
for shipping between the Atlantic and
the Great Lakes along with massive
hydroelectric power plants that
expansion came to cost though the water
is high today but when it's low you can
still see the foundations of alts ville
Ontario one of the lost villages that
were flooded to make way for progress
the residents were told they had to move
and see their old town demolished and
then ground beneath new higher water
they didn't really have any choice in
the matter and then some scientists came
along and said these homes are going to
be demolished and then flooded anyway
can we set them on fire first the st.
Lawrence burns was a project where they
were trying to study how fires develop
in buildings specifically how it affects
the survival of the occupants as well as
how fire spreads from one building to
another the researchers were scientists
from the building research division of
the National Research Council of Canada
they burn a total of eight buildings
including six single-family dwelling
homes one two-story school and one
Community Hall this was a rare
opportunity because up until this point
most of the research that was done on
fires were either from the aftermath of
real fires or they did it on small-scale
lab tests this the st. Lawrence burns
was really the first time that
scientists were able to conduct infield
full-scale research where they had
control over the parameters as well as
being able to observe the fire from
beginning to end there's a fair argument
that if the buildings were going to be
destroyed anyway why not take the
opportunity to get useful data from them
whether it's by fire or by water the
result was going to be the same but it's
also tough to ignore the human element
homes that have been families for
generations the local school the
community hall all given a sort of
insult to injury by folks coming in from
outside for science many people weren't
even told about the burns others chose
not to watch the Volunteer Fire Chief
said an interview years later that
watching the flames was devastating but
the results were probably worth it they
got a lot of different data including
things
like carbon monoxide concentrations
smoke density rise of temperature oxygen
levels they mounted a microphone in the
bedroom they found out that the noise
levels that was produced by a fire was
not enough to wake a sleeping occupant
when the bedroom door is closed the
Assumption prior to the studies was that
convection was the biggest cause of fire
spread but then it turns out it was
actually a radiant heat that was more
likely the culprit a combustible wood
frame house could lead to another house
40 feet away to ignite and even in a non
combustible building it could cause
another house about 32 feet away to
ignite the st. Lawrence burns helped
change the National Building Code of
Canada and it saved lives old smell has
almost passed out of living memory today
on aerial photos you can still see
ghosts of old roads structures that
haven't been worn away by the water yet
but you could say there's a little bit
of old smell in every modern home in
everything that's been built in the
developed world from the 1960s onwards
because the results from the st.
Lawrence burns here really did change
the way that everything was built thank
you very much to betty chen from
articulations where i do videos about
art and design you'll want to go and
check out her video about the iso
standard exit sign it's not all signs
and infrastructure like here but it is a
great little channel that's pretty
little